we're doing never have i ever news
edition
all today's news stories are inspired by
real headlines with a never have i ever
twist
file this first story under never have i
ever
gone streaking huh stuff
magazine which i can't believe that's
the name reports that i knew that a
rugby club in new zealand
recently had such a problem with
streaking that officials said police had
to
beg fans to stop ruining the game
ruining it or making it oh i don't know
i'm gonna go with making it just after
their last match
five nudie duties in separate runs
showed off their offsides
and they were banned for two years
all i can say is thank god there was no
social media in the 90s i think i never
had
clothes on i mean seriously i did like
i was constantly naked i was like i
don't know you would have thought i was
living in like woodstock
the movie anyway it was fun
never have i ever ghosted someone
yahoo life reports on a new study that
finds that ghosting
disappearing from a romantic interest is
actually on the decline
but cuffing cozying up with a partner
for the winter months
is on the rise some experts say it's a
result of self-reflection that took
place during this last year's extended
alone time that's sweet
but maybe it's not so wholesome and more
about finding a
cuff buddy
call me christine next up never have i
ever stolen something an official in
brazil was busted for embezzling
government funds
after police noticed a rectangular bulge
in his underwear
yeah it was full of cash and finally
we have never ever ever ever ever been
to mars as a species
but my next guest might be the first
human to do it
she is 19 year old from louisiana
who has already achieved some big firsts
get this she's the first person to
attend
every nasa space camp and she's the
youngest graduate
ever of the advanced space academy and
she's here to tell us about her mission
to be the first person on mars
i am betting on her please welcome
alyssa carson
hi alyssa hi it's nice to meet you
it's really nice to meet you you're so
impressive what was the catalyst why
mars when did it start
yeah totally i mean looking back i got
interested in
the idea of going to mars and being an
astronaut at a really young age so i
don't remember it
all perfectly me and my dad kind of our
best guess that's where it started was
actually an episode of the backyard
again so
basically i had the poster in my bedroom
of the cartoon with mission to mars so
it's really the only place we can think
of as to where i would have heard the
word mars to begin with
then my daughter is definitely going to
go live in bikini bottom because she
watches a lot of spongebob
so maybe she'll become like a world
famous scuba diver and check out that
whole universe
um when does nasa think that we would
even possibly get to mars like what are
the biggest challenges
it seems so improbable is it possible
yeah totally so right now kind of the
plans are to start going back to the
moon um sometime in the 2020s and then
eventually onto mars
in the early 2030s so that's the plan um
and we're kind of working up to that
point of course there's still challenges
that we need to do to get there
um still building the rocket the capsule
all of those things there's you know
problems with radiation or food supply
or
muscle loss of the astronauts but all
those problems that we do have there's
constant research being done right now
to eventually get all figured out
for the 2030s i mean there's no oxygen
right and it's 81 degrees
fahrenheit is that right
negative i was like that smells pretty
pleasant to me
by the way i'm reading all this off of
prompter i don't know
about mars but i can tell you a lot
about venus because my daughter and i
studied it this year for school
um and i still love pluto and i feel bad
it's been kicked off the list
it's not very fair um but
i'm so fascinated with like again i'm
the mother to two daughters
and i so wonder who and what they're
gonna be
when they grow up do your parents tell
you that they're so proud of you
well i mean honestly my dad has been a
huge supporter
basically ever since i was a little girl
you know when i was younger he went to
space camp with me so we did all the
crazy simulators we've traveled all over
the world together so it's been a really
awesome bonding experience as well
do you know emily calandreli i do
i do um i was wearing this earth first
hat when i was talking to her and then i
realized
that it was more universe first
so now that i'm making sure to promote
the universe first
like what do you say to young women
who are interested in taking care of the
earth
or space exploration what do you promote
that
young girls should be focusing on i
absolutely love being able to speak to
girls and inspire them to
you know follow whatever their dreams
may be whether that is you know being an
astronaut being an engineer being all
these other things or
careers that they can go into i do know
that when i was little
you know saying i want to be an
astronaut and go to mars was about the
most crazy thing i could have ever
picked
but the more i've worked towards it the
more of a reality it's becoming
so definitely just encouraging them to
stick with whatever and it's been so
awesome to be able to have that
but it's a little girl coming up to me
after i'm speaking and saying oh now i
want to be an astronaut or
whatever those little moments may be
it's really awesome to be able to
inspire them
well i don't think anything you're
saying is sounding crazy
and it probably won't to any little
girls i think you are just
impressive beyond impressive and alyssa
i'd love
to check back in with you and hear how
everything is going and keep
track on your journey because it is
impressive
as well are you thank you alyssa so much
i really really appreciate your time and
i can't wait to see
all the places that you'll go
[Music]